Democratic Senator Elizabeth Warren, who is
running for president as well, has released
a plan
or how to pay for Medicare for all. And we're
going to go through it and we're going to
break it down, but we do need some important
context in order to do this correctly. One
controversy around Elizabeth Warren and Medicare
for all is that there is a criticism of her
that she's not really for Medicare for all
at all, but that maybe she's open to it along
with lots of other ideas, which are actually
the ones that she would pursue. And if that's
true, then that is absolutely a concern. Now,
lately I'm seeing her talk more and more about
how Medicare for all is the way being more
and more for it. Even in supposedly leaked
behind the scenes, private video talking to
union leaders, she still was talking about
how Medicare for all she believes is the way
to get the most care to the most people, the
most cheap, uh, the, the, the in the most
affordable way possible.
So that's number one. And certainly putting
out a plan for how to pay for it is a good
sign that she's taking it seriously. Second
piece of context, there are questions specifically
around the cost of Medicare for all that I've
brought up. Medicare for all can still be
the best plan. I still support Medicare for
all, but at the same time, if there are unanswered
questions, if there are real criticisms of
it, not dumb ones like the U S has a lot of
people so it wouldn't work. That's a dumb
criticism. We've already talked about that
there are real criticisms and on the left
we want to be prepared to address and deal
with those. Now I know that there are people
on the left who will say, but David, nothing
on the right ever has to be perfect and they
do it anyway, so why does everything we do
have to be perfect?
It doesn't have to be perfect and in fact
it's not, and it may still still be the best
thing and the one the path most worth pursuing.
But we should not pretend that these questions
don't exist because we want to be equipped
to answer them. So to remind you the problems
with most of the prior plans for how to pay
for Medicare for all are mostly twofold. Problem.
One is that many of the plans that say here's
how much it will cost and how we pay for it,
they are assuming a drastic reduction in healthcare
costs in the U S to the levels of Australia
and Canada, which are about half of ours in
order to make the numbers work. But they don't
say how they would do that. They say we will
do it, but they don't say how. And the reality
is that the health insurance bureaucracy that
we have does add costs to the system.
So if you get rid of that with a Medicare
for all system, you do shaved some of the
costs, but only a little bit of what you would
need to shave in order to cut the price of
our care delivery by 50% which is what Australia
and Canada have. If you can't explain how
to do that, the numbers don't work. That's
a problem with a lot of the plans that are
out there. Number two, the other issue is
that a lot of the plans, um, for Medicare
for all include these phrases that nobody
in the middle class is going to pay more in
the net, but we've not seen the middle-class
defined and you can get pretty slippery with
that. And then lastly, there's also the question
of would Elizabeth Warren or anyone else's
plan make private insurance illegal as an
industry? Or would it simply say, let whatever
happens to private insurance happen if people
want it, okay, it'll probably go up in cost
as people get out of it.
And that's it. And I tend to favor that. I
think that it's the, I think it's legally
difficult to say this industry can no longer
exist anymore. So I think the, as they like
to say, the free market solution should be
applied. If hundreds of millions of people
get out of private insurance, I think the
problem will sort of solve itself. Okay, so
let's look at Elizabeth Warren's plan for
how to pay for Medicare for all. Now as we
look at this list, understand that lots of
this is controversial and I'm not going to
hide that from you. First of all, Warren estimates
the cost at 20 point $5 trillion in additional
spending by the federal government over 10
years. This is much lower than what the urban
Institute analysis says. They have a very
detailed projection, which says it'll cost
34 trillion additional over 10 years. That
alone, like if that's true, if the cost is
really 34 instead of 20 and a half, that already
makes Warren's math completely wrong.
Now, there's already some confusion about
these numbers. On the one hand, she says it'll
cost 20 point 5 trillion. But on the other
hand, she says on our website that it's a
$52 trillion over 10 year plan, which is it?
It's sort of both. And this is confusing and
it relates to the fact that some of the existing
costs paid by consumers would instead stay
in the pockets of consumers. But then there
will be new spending that has to make up for
that, which is what they call a additional
federal spending. But the idea is either way,
the baseline is 52 trillion over 10 years.
In one case, the government is in the middle
and that's what needs to be additionally funded.
Now if you look at the savings that Elizabeth
Warren lists or where she would, uh, pay for,
um, uh, these, uh, where the money would come
from to pay for this additional spending,
she says, eight point 8 trillion comes from
employers.
Instead of paying health insurance premiums
to private insurers, they start paying the
government through a payroll tax. That's eight
point 8 trillion. 2 trillion comes from taxing
the investment gains of the top 1%. 1 trillion
comes from a wealth tax on billionaires. 800
billion comes from taxes on financial transactions,
and then six point 1 trillion is contributed
by the States. That adds up. Uh, and then,
uh, she also, uh, you know, is assuming drastically
lower costs, which we're going to talk about
in a moment. These numbers add up if you believe
the additional spending is 20 and a half trillion
instead of the 34 trillion, which the urban
Institute says it will. And that gets us to
the assumptions about lower prescription drug
prices and reducing administrative spending,
but more importantly, reducing what we pay
for healthcare period. And this is where her
plan falls short. This is not unique to Elizabeth
Warren.
She assumes that health care costs will number
one drop to be much closer to those of other
countries. And number two, grow much more
slowly than anticipated. You have to defend
those assumptions because they are huge, complicated
things. And as yet she doesn't appropriately
defend them in her plan. This is not me being
a Warren attacker nor a Warren shill. This
is me just looking at the data and the criticisms.
If you look at Elizabeth Warren's plan on
her website, it is assumed as a foregone conclusion
that healthcare spending drops drastically
and rapidly and almost immediately when you
switch to Medicare for all. I already told
you in my general analysis, L analysis of
how to pay for Medicare for all that serious
experts, even experts on the left say that
these expectations are unrealistic. There
are estimates that in the best of cases, it
could take decades to tamp down healthcare
costs in the U S to make 20 point 5 trillion.
A realistic number, a more realistic number
is 34 trillion as cited by the urban Institute.
So to be completely Frank, this is a fine
plan. It's not drastically different than
most of the other plans that we've seen. And
it's, it's a problem is it counts on drastic
reductions in healthcare spending that cannot
be assumed unless you explain why is the urban
Institute and other economists that have looked
at this, why are they wrong and why is Elizabeth
Warren, right? Or why is Bernie right about
the drastic reductions in spending? Because
you can't attribute it simply to changing
systems. Simply going from a private insurance
system to Medicare for all doesn't drop healthcare
spending by the 50% it would need to drop
to match that of Australia or Canada. All
this being said, Medicare for all may still
be the best plan even at 34 trillion in additional
spending over 10 years, but we've got to figure
out how to pay for that.
It's doable, but we just have to be honest
about the numbers and this is now the trend
that the pro proposals that are being put
forward for how to pay for it have extraordinarily
optimistic numbers about the costs, which
serious think tanks and economists simply
don't agree with that being said, Warren being
more and more behind Medicare for all. That's
good, but we've got resolve this issue because
otherwise it either will not happen even with
a democratic president who, or it'll happen
and we will be shocked at how much more it
will cost, which is also a problem. If we're
going to do it, let's do it right based on
what it'll actually cost. We've got to deal
with it at some point in time and I hope it
gets dealt with soon.